we were looking out in certainly code
name bulk storage and users growing to
hundreds of terabytes petabytes and a
lot of menu intervention for things like
they are not business was reading on
your twenty four by seven approach at
the heart of sky we're about content
right and as a media television company
we have a huge amount of unstructured
data and when your storage platform that
enables us to support the data that we
have today will also scale or so that we
can meet the needs of tomorrow we start
looking object storage that's a lot of
people so enterprise vendors new
companies and we really liked what we
saw pretty likely technology so we sort
of meeting with them in it was a very
close cultural feel very good when any
technology that we choose Security's
part most paramount decision that we
that we kind of look at evaluation
clever sakes approach the software
engineering has been to make sure that
security is theme through the
development lifecycle and we can see
that in the product today as a customer
it's really simple meet some more rice
and commodity hardware and we plug it in
and expand the service safe installation
it's a really really simple selling to
very agile and accessibility storage is
all done by restful api ways it's all
incredibly fast no no he to talk to us
on time tire and going in to face this
string to the crevice new technology
they're brilliant cultural fair they've
worked with us in a number of
initiatives to build the product and
extend the product right to get it right
for us and it's great to see a young
company with that kind of agility and
commitment to work with their customers
let's reinvent a lot for us it's a great
function